we've been talking of course in the show
a lot about the London Bridge terror
attack where two people tragically died
when the 28 year old is min can launch
the attack on Friday before he was shot
dead by police and just as in the last
general election a terror attack of
course it's the focus of the campaign
squarely on to security and policing
we've already heard jeremy corbyn's
response and the Conservatives are
making several announcements today about
how they want to tighten the nation's
security well to talk about all of that
but join now in the studio by the
Foreign Secretary Dominik Roth thank you
very much for being good morning it
feels that we should start with the
terror attack course how many convicted
terrorists are on the streets of London
all the rest of the country today I'm
not sure the total number but the
reality is we've given a big boost to
counterterrorism policing by 160 million
it's up by a third since 2015 we've made
sure the security services have all the
powers that they need we strengthened
these sentences for terrorist offences
which Osman Khan was subject to which
allowed for automatic release at the
halfway point and you've heard from the
Prime Minister that he would increase
them again wants to make sure
terrace defenders serve their full
sentence in prison that's the difference
between what he's saying and what Jeremy
Corbyn isn't I think a big issue come
the 12th of December is who out of
Jeremy Corbyn and Boris Johnson is best
placed to protect the people this
country all your voters and your viewers
will be making their mind up you see and
I just want to go back to the numbers
question and I accept you don't have
every single number in front of you and
the Sunday Telegraph they're reporting
today saying there were up to 70 violent
terrorists free from jail and on the
streets
how can people feel safe if that is the
correct number well that's all the more
reason and I don't know about those
figures I'm not sure I can't confirm or
deny them and but that's all the more
reason that we make sure we've got the
police powers in place how can we make
sure well I'm sure the numbers I can't
tell the top my head and I want to with
such a sensitive issue be very careful
but that's why we've said look we've got
the security the intelligence agencies
have done an amazing job in recent years
and with some of these so-called lone
wolf attacks which we believe this one
to have been it's very difficult
but the reality is there is well I think
the head of mi5 once said there is no
zero risk Society which is also free but
our approach is crystal clear you back
the police with the resources and the
powers we would never call into question
what we saw on London Bridge on Friday
which was the application very difficult
circumstances shoot to kill Jeremy
Corbyn in 2014 after the Paris terrorist
attacks although it's important to say
that in the interview that I just did
with Jeremy Corbyn he said very clearly
that the police had no choice but to
shoot dead the suspect and the in
matters of life or death
it is the right but he's got a track
record after the Paris attacks in 2002
yesterday well okay well I'm not sure
what about with it not in the heat of a
general actually had been we saw in
relation to Albert dadly who was
targeted and is a senior Islamic state
leader he suggested that actually no
ideal scenario he could be arrested I
was I began with parents not what you
said in the past and I think people
again it comes down to trust in
politicians question is for people
watching this show who do they trust
Boris Johnson to keep us safe or Jeremy
Corbyn with his track record I just want
to give you the opportunity as well to
respond to what David was saying I'm not
sure if you heard the interview about
the prime minister saying he was the
most dishonest prime minister in history
that he's been misleading people by
saying that terrorists are effectively
automatically released halfway through
their sentences that's not the case now
well it's not the case now because the
change is that we introduced as
conservatives but on trust and I heard a
Devi attacking the Prime Minister the
biggest dupe of trust from the Liberal
Democrats he's not giving effect to
referendum on brexit while calling
yourself a democratic party and at the
same time now frankly campaigning for a
hung parliament within which they would
support Jeremy called them with two more
referendums all of the uncertainty that
did that would never get out of this
route and I think that's the big dupe
from the Liberal Democrats and that's
why if you want to get out of the
paralysis we're in you the only thing
you can do is vote conserved on the 12th
of December to get a working functional
government to get brexit delivered to
keep our people safe and to get the
economy moving forward
let's talk now about what the government
would do going forward in the wake of
course of what we've seen in the last
week because lots of people will be
going into the selection thinking who do
I most trust to keep me safe because he
measures that they're going to take
Lisbon can of course was released
halfway through sentence because he fell
back on an old regime that wouldn't
happen now he'd go in front of a parole
board wouldn't he so what do you want to
change when it comes to sentence and the
first thing says the old regime was a
regime provided by by the last Labour
government a new regime we changed we've
said that we would expect for the
serious terrorist offences a minimum 14
year sentence we don't think that it is
the case that they should all
necessarily be released we think for
some offenses they should be imprisoned
for life and we also think that
terrorist offenders should serve their
full sentence both as a matter of public
protection and also confidence in the
system and again I think again you saw
the difference with Jeremy Corbyn who
said that offenders shouldn't
necessarily serve their full sentence so
when you ask the question which I think
you rightly did Sophie who do you trust
to keep her safe again I think it's the
Conservatives in Boris Johnson who are
willing to take the measures in these
very difficult challenging times to keep
Britain's safe but you accept that
husband Khan may not have been released
under the current rules as they stand
because he would have to go in front of
the parole board that's true so he would
have been released and it gained it's
difficult because you but he would be
released at the two-third stage not the
halfway stages under the last Labour
government regime and only with a parole
board assessment of risk which was
airbrushed out of the approach that he
was actually sentenced under in relation
to the previous Labour Party Labour
government legislation so that's the
difference okay
now I just don't have a quick look and
there's a difficult subject it's a very
emotive subject but I do just want to
have a quick look at something that the
father of one of the victims had said in
recent days it's very war of course but
this is David Merritt the the father of
Jack Merritt he said my son Jack who was
killed in this attack would not wish his
death to be used as the pretext for more
draconian sentences or for detaining
people unnecessarily we need to listen
to the victim's father hidden totally
and no one see the politicization was
equally first question you asked
understandably so voters will have it on
their mind but we're talking about
people have been convicted by a jury in
court and the question is not whether
they've been unnecessarily arbitrarily
detained the question is what's who's
going to make sure that the overriding
priority is avoiding any unnecessary
risk to the public and I think if you
look at what we're saying on sentencing
also on supporting our security services
making sure that the police have got our
back got their backing from the
politicians when they've got to make
those difficult calls as they did on
London Bridge it is the Conservatives
who are saying we will stop at nothing
to make sure people are kept safe he's
talking about saying he doesn't want his
son's death to be used as a pretext for
detaining people unnecessarily yes some
would look at what you're proposing
which is effectively to make sure that
someone serves every day of their
sentence no matter what the proble
parole board says even for parole board
says that they're no longer a threat
that that would be an unnecessary
detention so if you I don't think after
what we've seen both in this election
and in the previous election and the
kind of individuals involved that anyone
would think taking the measures
necessary to protect the public and
putting their interest and their safety
at the forefront and as the overriding
priority would be somehow politicization
I think it's the the necessary thing to
do to keep people safe and it is only
this Prime Minister and the
Conservatives who are offering that okay
now you're also talking about a shift in
the balance that you want to see between
security and human rights what do you
mean when you're talking about this well
of course one of the things we're trying
to preserve is the freedoms and the
quality of life that make this country
such a great place to live we can't
throw those away but in relation to
things like deportation we do think that
public protection and avoiding this
country that being allowed to have being
forced to keep people who either serious
criminals extremists or terrorists we
ought to be able to have clearer powers
to deport and I think there are other
areas as well but that's one very
concrete example we've been talking
about this something it's in our
manifesto there's not something that has
been spurred by this terrorist attack
it's something that we've been looking
at more broadly and of course when we
leave the EU we'll take back control of
our borders so one of the key things
we'll be able to do and it was very much
relevant to the 2015 2014 attacks is how
full control to
check people coming into this country
and bar them from entry if they if it's
not conducive to the public good the
moment we can only do that if they come
from outside of Europe and one of the
big advantages of leaving that EU will
be actually will have stronger
preventative powers at the border and
again only the Conservatives back in
that we are talking a lot here about how
to keep people safe sure and one thing
that's many people would say is
absolutely at the heart of that is
police numbers yes we just have a quick
look at how police numbers have changed
in the last decades so this basically
shows the police numbers in England and
Wales and and that they dropped by
twenty three thousand between 2010 when
the Conservatives came into power in the
coalition government and 2018 now you
want to hire an extra twenty thousand
officers of course but this is just
effectively putting us back on or even
quite back to 2010 levels isn't it I
mean can you now look at that map and
say that this graph and say this was a
mistake this may put people at risk
well crime has come down by a third on
this government but what we're talking
about here I think the way the reason
you're linking in is the terrorist
security threat and we have boosted
counterterrorism policing by 160 million
last year it's up by a third since 2015
and as you say we're already recruiting
you're putting these so that you could
put those words into my mouth of course
they matter you've got to keep the
resources that powers the sentencing
continually under review but again we
come back to who's on the side of the
public when it comes to keeping them
safe and last February we put our
proposals to increase police funding
across the board not just
counterterrorism Neil close to 1 billion
pounds in the House of Commons Jeremy
Corbyn whipped his MPs against that so
again on this crucial issue
it's the Conservatives are saying look
we understand the risk you cost course
you keep crime and particular
counterterrorism constant and review we
will back the authorities whether it's
the eight security forces as the
intelligence agencies the police and
also back them in terms of not just a
resource but their powers to do the job
if there's either a link between police
numbers and crime or there isn't
do you not accept that cutting there's a
number of police officers has made
people less safe
well I think over if you look at police
we call the crime over the pier
since 2010 it came down my fingers can
take or there's a lag often isn't that
but that's why you cannot be seen
straight away but I think that answers
your question it's not necessary
hydraulic clink you have to keep it
continually under review and in
particular of course crime is different
when you're talking about antisocial
behavior in a neighborhood or you
talking about hey we made a mistake and
we're trying to rectify it we open we
certainly do accept the case for more
funding not just for counterterrorism
policing which has already been
increased but for neighborhood policing
and it is the Labour Party that opposed
those plans in February okay you see it
there is it I know you want to talk
about security we won't talk about
sentencing how so many people will say
that actually the years of austerity and
rich conservative-led government has
contributed to the safety of people in
this country we've talked about police
numbers you know you've got the Ministry
of Justice budget you part privatized of
probation service which many people
think was a disaster I mean a lot of the
problems you're talking about fixing now
are problems that are the responsibility
of the Conservatives being in power
since 2010 oh you're quite right in 2010
we came in under the last Labour
government which is far more moderate
than jeremy corbyn's Labour Party we've
had the biggest recession since the war
we'd had you asked me about the
decisions we had to make I'm talking
about the decisions the questions it's
only fair fuel for your viewers and we
have the biggest budget deficit since
the war so we have had an age of
recovery we've had to make difficult
decisions in order to get the economy
and the country back on track what the
government is now saying Sajid Javid
Boris Johnson we've got a decade now of
renewal in front of us we're looking at
all of the issues where public service
needs a further investment levelling up
schools funding because you want every
child no matter what their background to
reach their full potential and
absolutely if you look at what the
Conservatives are offering on policing
counterterrorism policing the powers of
the police and the intelligence agencies
we are the ones sharp contrast to the
Labour government under Labour Party
under Jeremy Corbyn who are willing to
take the measures to keep people safe
and I think that's the issue of trust
that voters are going to ask
come the 12th of December when it comes
to security ok now you're also
announcing a review into
defense and foreign policy something of
course that your departments very
involved in my question is I've already
had the review and worked out what
you're actually going to be doing and
predict people in your manifesto we
continually update and have strategic
defence reviews but it's actually right
that you do that out of the day to day
or the annual cut and thrust of the
budget process that we go through we're
looking at everything from cybersecurity
countering - on NATO alliances we've got
the NATO leaders meeting coming up this
week we've got our European and our
American allies coming here Prime
Minister is a leading light but in terms
of both NATO defence spending but also
operational support we're the one thing
we've got to keep that team together
Europeans and the Americans we've got to
forge an even stronger consensus to
counter - and Jeremy Corbyn has called
into question he said I think it was
2015 or maybe 2014 but actually NATO
should shut up shop close down a go away
so whether it's the domestic powers
we've got to take or leading
internationally with all our allies it's
only this Prime Minister and the
Conservatives that are taking the
measures leading by example to keep
Britain's safe and of course the key
thing about the foreign policy it does
have a an impact back on our security
and on the the safety of people on our
streets in this country I mean Jeremy
Corbyn is not the only one with concerns
about NATO though is he Emmanuel macron
the French president said it was brain
dead right well no we don't agree with
that analysis I understand that people
can have criticisms of NATO it does need
to adapt but the answer is to reform it
and to strengthen it and to bring
together our French friends our German
friends our European friends across the
board with our American and North
American friends and actually we're
probably closer to the German position
and what anglo Merkel said about this
which we should be calling into question
NATO we should be strengthening we
certainly shouldn't be saying it should
shut up shop which is what jeremy
corbyn's position is and when it comes
to keeping us safe it's not just what we
do at the domestic level it's leading
internationally and bringing our allies
together Boris Johnson is doing that I'm
talking about allies and Donald Trump
it's gonna be in town it's a little bit
of nervousness that you could you know
say something that's gonna perhaps
jeopardize some of the messaging of your
campaign I don't think so we were proud
that we're host
the leaders summit here it's quite right
we do that and actually on the
international stage from NATO to next
year when we're hosting the UN climate
change talks it is under the
Conservatives this government that wants
the UK to lead we don't just want to
bring this country together we want the
UK to be bringing other country
countries together to tackle the global
challenges we face from security with
NATO through to climate change in the US
so no nervousness at all that Donald
Trump may say something and he'll for
all perhaps tweet something no I'm not
going to give succor to some of the
anti-americanism we've heard from some
of the other parties the u.s. is our
closest and oldest ally we work very
closely with them and it's the most
important allied the u.s. I think
historically has been but of course what
we really want to do is bring our
European American friends together
because we think we're stronger when we
stand shoulder-to-shoulder
whether that's dealing with - whether
it's tackling cyber crime whether it's
facing up to the Menace of Russia which
of course when we had the Salisbury
attack in 2018 it was Boris Johnson as
foreign secretary who led the
international response to it whereas
actually when push came to shove Jeremy
Corbyn sided with Vladimir Putin and
questioned whether those attacks had
taken place again when it comes down to
the fundamental question of who is fit
to lead and keep Britain safe I think
the choice is clear for you let your
viewers and for voters as between jeremy
corbyn's position and the the
conservatism well lead the viewers to
make up their own minds of who they're
going to be voting for and talking about
Jeremy Corbyn in the interview I did
with him he said that when asked what
improvements he would like to see with
the royal family he talked about the
size and that there was a lot of people
in the royal family
do you think the size of the royal
family should come down now I think it's
crazy we need to be respecting the
institution of the monarchy and if
Jeremy Corbyn is saying he wants to cut
the number of members of the royal
family he should come out and say who he
wants to cut I think it's crazy for us
to get drawn into that the public have
great respect for the monarchy as an
institution obviously there are some
issues right now with Prince Andrew it's
for him to answer for those but frankly
I was left with more questions than
answers from what jeremy corbyn said I
mean he suggests being respected
institution but think it should be
improved
it's but he was talking about cutting
the numbers who does he want to cut
I love to know who-who did he have in
mind that was what I was wondering when
he said he wanted to cut the size that
they're all they're all family
I don't think politicians should be
getting into all of that we should be
focusing what the voters really care
about we've had these really serious
terrorist attack on Friday we've got
brexit we've got all the bread and
butter issues cost of living the economy
jobs people care about and being drawn
into that frankly feels like he doesn't
want to talk about the number one issue
in this election campaign which is who
can deliver brexit who can get Britain
motoring forward and that's only going
to happen if we avoid a hung parliament
and you can only do that by voting
conservative talking about how people
voting there's been a few slightly
nerve-racking polls about your own
constituency and you or as you might be
the next Portillo at this election
not really but look at the well the
truth is with a seat like mine never
take anything for granted and the polls
will flew in all over the place but one
thing it does show you in my
constituency and up and down the country
is the risk of a hung parliament and
that is a very real risk if you vote any
other way than conservative but we've
got a really positive plan to get brexit
done to get the country moving forward
and I'm confident taking that talking
about hung parliament the polls do look
like they're tightening slightly don't
they it's not something you're concerned
about they I think they do look like
they're tightening and I think the the
choice in this election is now coming
into sharper focus because we'll either
have a workable functioning majority
under the Conservatives that can get
break sit down get the economy moving
forward invested in the NHS schools
funding get more police on the street or
we're going to have all of the
uncertainty all of the paralysis of
another hung parliament with the Lib
Dems the SP propping up Jeremy Corbyn
with all that means for the economy
although they've said they wouldn't do
the dance
well it seems to me inconceivable
they're not sure they have said that
what they've said is they wouldn't go
into coalition I have said that they
said that to me they won't go to
coalition that they wouldn't prop up
Jeremy Corbyn I think it's what are they
what do they care about I think I think
they're talking about potentially
getting somebody else to lead so we're
gonna have in fact we don't know if
you're voting for the Lib Dems are
certainly not voting for them they don't
even know who they would want to be
Prime Minister this country that just
shines a light on the uncertainty but I
think we've got to avoid and I'm
confident going in to the run-up to a
polling day that a lot of people focus
on the choice Funk
workable majority under the
Conservatives in Boris Johnson or all of
that uncertainty and chaos if you vote
for Jeremy Corbyn or any of those other
parties okay Dominic Rob thank you very
much thing I'm good to talk today thank
you